Freak bitches,
but in fact your original question of
why am I thinking about simplifying and
all those kinds of stuff.
I am a pretty light positive person.
Very optimistic,
very.
I kind of live in that world,
but when I just started reading the book,
are things really pissing me off?
Am I stressed?
Do I have anxiety because I live in this
house because I'm trying to do these
things with my career because I'm trying
to always do this because I'm carrying
children and parents
and all of this stuff.
I'm trying to make everybody happy.
I'm just,
I don't know,
maybe just realizing that
and thinking about it.
I'm didn't.
No heavy meditation on it.
No.
Just being aware that maybe
that's where it's coming from.
I'm telling you over a month and a half
the pain slowly went away and I don't
have it.
Hm.
Yeah.
That is interesting.
So what,
like what was bothering you before?
Like I know that you're,
you know,
you're successful and you had a television
show for awhile and you've got a
bunch of projects going on.
You're always doing standup and specials,
so you have had a lot of success.
You've got a lot of great stuff going on.
What was,
what was kind of chew and at you?
I don't know.
I'm not really 100 percent
sure of what the sources,
but I do feel like I have a lot
of people on my back and it's all,
it's all quiet.
It's all in my head,
you know what I mean?
A lot of people on your back.
Yeah.
I've got a wife.
I've got,
I've got kids,
I've got pets,
I've got family.
I've got
in the end that you feel
that there's a weird,
a weird way to um,
bring,
bring this up.
But there's that.
How much of that like having
a wife and having kids,
obviously there's going to be compromises
and there's going to be stressed that
comes along with any sort of relationship.
But do you feel like it was tipping more
towards the negative than towards the
positive?
Um,
I don't think it was.
I think I just,
uh,
the whole experience to me seems positive.
My relationship with my wife is great.
The kids I adore,
I feel like it's all positive,
but I do carry the burden of everybody's
worries and everybody's wellbeing all
the time.
I was working on this act,
this joke in my act before I started
thinking about all this stuff I had this
moment where I'm standing in this house,
I moved to this bigger house.
It's a really nice house to bigger,
bigger home and I was shutting off all
the lights is what I was working through
onstage and I was turning off all the
lights one night and locking the doors for
all the bad people that
are coming to get us.
And everyone's in their beds and the
cat's asleep and the dog's asleep and
everybody the Lizard Asleep.
And it just,
all my responsibility washed over me.
Like everybody,
every living thing here is,
is,
uh,
depending on my success.
If I don't keep going,
if I don't keep succeeding this,
everything here changes
everybody's little life.
Everybody's perfect,
perfect little existence.
It's all washing over me and
I can't tell anyone about it.
I can tell you the audience,
but I can't go sit on my daughter's bed
at two in the morning when I have that
feeling.
Honey,
do you ever.
Do you ever feel like he
just can't do it anymore?
You ever feel like you can't.
He just want to stop.
He just wanted to take a break.
This whole thing about waking
up my daughter with my fears.
I can't do that.
I don't tell my wife that stuff.
I don't tell my kids that stuff.
I just carry it.
So when I started reading
this book I'm like,
maybe I'm just taking this really
seriously and feeling like,
hm.
Yeah,
I used to have to deal with a lot more.
I used to choose to deal with it a lot
more and now it's just like I'm 46.
I don't know.
I'll tell you like there was a person
who came to one of the screenings on the
road.
We had the screening at.
Um,
fuck,
I forgot where we were.
I want to say New Orleans and of Yoga
hosers I was doing q and a afterwards and
you know,
everyone's getting up and like,
oh,
that's fucking stupid.
And asking questions and then one guy
gets up and he is like tight dude.
He's very serious and he's just like,
uh,
okay.
You told the big long story
before that movie began and I did.
It was a big intro for the movement.
Began told like an hour long
story of how we got there.
And he goes,
that story did not match
the movie I just watched.
And I said,
no.
And he goes,
not at all.
why did you make that movie?
He's gone.
I found that unwatchable as and
everyone in the audience has gone.
Oh.
And I was like,
no many,
he paid like he overpaid to see this
movie if I'm sitting here talking.
So yeah,
let him say what he want,
like I'm a big boy and fine.
And so he goes,
I just don't think you
ever should have made it.
It's terrible.
And I said,
well,
you understand that subjective,
right?
Like you're surrounded by a bunch of
people that feel like the opposite way.
Um,
so,
you know,
when people were applauding
and shit and then uh,
some guy behind him in line jumps
in front of the mic and goes,
you want me to kick his ass?
And I was like,
fuck no.
I was like,
everyone's entitled to their opinion.
I said,
but his opinion is I never
should have done this.
And you know,
my answer to that is like,
that's ridiculous.
Like if,
if I wanted to make it,
like that's the only reason we're here,
I just want to see it.
Like you can choose not to see it.
And in this instance,
I'm really sorry that like you didn't,
artists didn't coincide,
but every time I go to do one of
these things I'd do it the same way.
Whether it was clerks up
to the most recent one.
I just make the movie I want to see.
And hopefully others like it.
And sometimes they do.
And that's amazing and it
feels great and you're like,
Holy Shit,
my fingers on the pulse.
And sometimes you're fucking alone.
But at least you're like,
I'm happy with the thing that I made.
I said,
but I feel heartbroken
that you came out of,
you're looking for
something I didn't give you.
So I said,
I'm going to give you your money back.
And I gave him 40 bucks and I was like,
put it on a riser,
a speaker.
And he goes,
I don't want that.
And I was like,
no man,
honestly take,
it's not a trick.
It's not like Jason Who's going to
come out and hit you with a hammer.
Just take it like,
I feel bad.
I want you to have a good
time and shit like that.
He goes,
no,
I don't want that.
And I was like,
dude,
it makes for an excellent story.
Like I told him his movie fucking blue
to his face and I fucking took his money
and walked out and he goes,
no.
And he went and sat down and crossed his
arms and just stayed there for another,
like half hour during the q and a.
So for him it was worth the
$40 bucks just to say it.
I'm going to visit a verb,
like just sit here and fucking hate on
this and let you know and then sit down
again so you know,
you deal with that,
but that's the memorable one
because that never happens.
Generally speaking,
like when we toured the movie,
you're touring and you're
in a safe zone dog.
I hated old edible about a month ago.
I found the back of my draw.
That thing fucked me up
was just like an expired it and you would
take an expired viking and you won't
have paid for a week.
Mouth.
I don't care how many
root canals they give.
You expired my pants,
my wife's,
my wife and watch that
tell you about that now.
A lot of
surgery.
I pop that motherfucking after it was
washing detergent stronger than ever.
Fucking I just found it.
I found it.
I wasn't even on the bike and I took
one out with me in case I had tooth pain
and those pain and I never
wore those pants again.
I go to Portland,
I go on the pants and that her,
she watched it right
before I went onstage.
I popped up out that motherfucker
who gives a fuck.
I don't need to know what it is anymore.
I've been through everything.
Pulling a do nothing dog.
Oh,
how strong was it?
Oh my God.
I took a half on stage and I blacked
out like the first 30 minutes.
I couldn't wait to get
back to the hotel room.
The other
radio the next day.
Oh my God.
Black the fuck.
I didn't know what came out of my mouth.
When you on radio you just start swearing.
No,
no,
no.
I'm headed to Portland Thursday night.
I'm in Portland.
I'm getting dressed.
When I was pulling pants,
these pants are darker
than my usual jeans.
I never wore.
I didn't want.
Well,
last time I went was probably when I had
the surgery and that's when I found the
pill in that they were clean.
I went into the detergent,
had won the numbers down,
so could have been anything,
so I just.
I said,
let me not be an answer.
I'll eat the whole thing.
People give me crazy shit all the time.
Let me break this and maybe somebody
gave it to me and I watched over it.
I knew it was like a viking
cousin to the village,
you know what I'm saying?
They had to be a cousin
or a brother in law,
something that bike.
I popped it.
I took a half and went to Portland.
I walked up those stairs and when
I sat down on top of the thing,
I was like,
I'm fucked up.
I smoked dogs,
but I tell you,
I set the fire alarm off and
the club on Friday night,
the fight in the dressing room and the
fucking fire department had to come
because the whole club blacks out,
all the lights go out and pilot
had to go onstage and
fucking Felicia what up?
Where?
It's just like,
do you want me to go up
there and check it out?
I go,
yeah,
that's how much of a comedy store she is.
Like somebody else has said,
well.